You don't need to be a Supreme Kai to know
how much of an influence the Dragon Ball Z
series has had on the world.
But there's a lot more to this franchise than
just fast fights, spiky hair, and screaming
at the top of your lungs.
With over $5 billion in franchise sales, DBZ
is a cornerstone of Japanese animation and
a cultural phenomenon, and the tale of Goku
and friends has had more twists and turns
than Snake Way.
Despite its impact, DBZ is only one part of
the story.
The Dragon Ball franchise has spawned four
original series, 19 movies, over 500 chapters
of manga, nearly 100 video games, and all
kinds of ridiculous memes and debates about
power levels.
So take a break from your training, take a
bite out of a senzu bean, and take a Grand
Tour with us through the untold truth of Dragon
Ball Z.
Dragon Boy
You might think Goku's story began with Akira
Toriyama's first Dragon Ball manga in a 1984
issue of Weekly Shonen Jump, but his origins
start way before that.
Toriyama, who'd already won multiple awards
for his hit comedy manga Dr. Slump, wanted
to do something drastically different for
his next project.
Mixing together sexual humor and early '80s
Jackie Chan-esque action-comedy, Toriyama
made the manga Dragon Boy, which served as
a short prototype to the Dragon Ball story.
A year later, Toriyama started a new Shonen
Jump manga series with Dragon Boy as its jumping-off
point, and the rest is history — literally.
Journey to the West
For inspiration in turning Dragon Boy to the
long-running Dragon Ball, Toriyama and his
team turned to older folklore, in particular
the 16th century novel Journey to the West.
The story featured the inspirations for Son
Goku, the Power Pole weapon, the Flying Nimbus
cloud, Bulma, Oolong the shapeshifting pig,
Yamcha the desert bandit, the Ox King, and
his castle on a fiery hill.
According to Toriyama's editor, Kazuhiko Torishima,
using these details to help hang the story
on was a matter of convenience.
As Torishima puts it, adding elements from
Journey to the West to the Dragon Boy story
was his idea.
He says, "The biggest reason for that was
it was a free intellectual property, as it
was very old.
In addition, when you need to make a long
running manga series, you need to add a lot
more features [...] So when we moved Dragon
Boy to a long running story format, that's
when the Journey to the West elements came
in."
The idea of gathering the seven dragon balls
to summon Shenron the wish-granting Eternal
Dragon was heavily inspired by the early 1800s
novel Nansō Satomi Hakkenden, also known
as The Eight Dogs Chronicles.
Hakkenden's story depicted a princess who
gave birth to eight crystal balls after getting
freaky with a dog.
The crystal balls then flew into the sky and
scattered across the world, just like the
dragon balls do after a wish, but became people
instead.
Considering the world of Dragon Ball features
all kinds of anthropomorphic animals, the
inspiration is pretty clear.
Good thing they left out most of the gross
stuff.
Goku grows up
When enthusiasm for Dragon Ball began to dwindle,
Torishima and Toriyama decided to drastically
change things, putting Goku on a quest to
become the strongest person ever, and the
series' emphasis shifted from comedy to action.
As a result, the final arc of Dragon Ball
was the Piccolo Jr. saga, which featured the
most intense fights of the series.
Goku was growing up.
Engagement with Dragon Ball spiked during
the action-filled final saga, leaving fans
clamoring for a continuation of the story.
Torishima later spoke about how they came
up with the title.
"I went and asked Toriyama for his input and
he answered immediately by saying 'Dragon
Ball Z … because this is last, nothing comes
after this.'"
DBZ was meant to be the end for Goku's story
— multiple times, usually with him passing
the torch to another hero.
Initially, the Frieza saga was meant to be
the final chapter, which shouldn’t surprise
anyone who’s seen it.
In that story, the franchise's longest fight,
Goku beats the strongest, most evil character
in the universe and ascends to an unbeatable
form.
The planet-ending saga was so epic it seemed
like a natural conclusion, but there would
still be a long way to go and many more transformations
before the series truly came to an end.
East meets west (and vice versa)
What does a franchise do when its creative
team runs out of ideas?
Go to space or travel through time — and
DBZ did both.
As the Super Saiyan success story continued,
Toriyama kept introducing more Western tropes.
Goku's alien backstory, abnormal strength,
and alien heritage was inspired by the lore
of Superman.
Goku (Superman) landed on Earth as a baby
and was raised like any other human.
He grew to fight members of his nearly-extinct
race trying to conquer Earth.
More story turns inspired by western media
include the outer space adventure to Namek,
which was largely influenced by Star Wars,
as well as the following Android saga, which
took inspiration from the Terminator movies.
Terminator 2: Judgment Day hit theaters in
July 1991 — by November of that year, DBZ
started a story arc featuring a badass guy
going back through time, trying to prevent
an apocalyptic future where cyborgs exterminated
humanity.
It helps explain why the series became such
an international phenomenon — its influenced
by enduring stories from all over the world.
Censorship and controversies
As the series entered the North American market,
a lot of changes were made in the translation,
mostly to make the series come off as more
kid-friendly.
All instances of death, heaven, and hell were
altered.
Vegeta wasn't "killing" Frieza's men — he
was simply sending them to the "next dimension."
The shirts on the ogres living there reading
"HELL" were partially censored to look like
the letters "HFIL”, standing for the "Home
For Infinite Losers."
Mr. Satan's name was changed to Hercule, and
scenes of cigarettes, blood, alcohol, nudity,
and middle fingers were all removed.
Changes have continued with re-airings of
the show on different networks, such as when
The CW changed up Mr. Popo’s look to make
him look less like a jarring blackface caricature.
We get the idea, but it kind of just makes
Mr. Popo look like a weirdly racist Genie
from Aladdin.
(Genie singing in stereotyped accents)
Evolution, god-battles, resurrection, and
beyond
After Dragon Ball Z ended in 1996, Toei Animation
wanted to continue the series due to its widespread
success.
As a result, Dragon Ball GT was created by
Toei's staff without any input from Toriyama
except for the series' name.
GT kept Goku's story going, but it was met
with negative reviews, failing to live up
to its predecessor without Toriyama at the
helm.
Save a few specials and movies, Dragon Ball
GT's final 1997 episode was the last time
television viewers in Japan would get to see
Goku and the gang for a long time.
During this time, Dragon Ball Z was just starting
to take off in North America.
When the episodes ran out, Dragon Ball was
spun off into the live-action Dragonball Evolution,
loosely based on the original Dragon Ball
story.
It’s... not a great adaptation.
"Meet Lord Piccolo.
He'll take on anyone to unleash his vengeance
on the world."
"I can't stand it!
Ugh!"
Toei tested the waters for the franchise's
return in 2009 with Dragon Ball Kai, a redubbed,
whittled-down version of DBZ with updated
animation.
The success of that series led to a revival
of the franchise, with Toriyama returning
for 2013's successful Dragon Ball Z: Battle
of Gods movie.
In its home country, it was a big deal — the
movie opened at the top of the Japanese box
office, and made its mark as the first Japanese
film to ever screen in IMAX.
The movie's critical and commercial success
opened the door for something fans never expected
— a whole new series, Dragon Ball Super.
So what's next for the Dragon Ball franchise?
Only time - and Goku's fists of fury - will
tell.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!